there you go and did magnus resign
yes i think he just wanted to make an
even match
yes i think he felt uh that was an
unfair
unjust uh results okay well that
that shows some sportsmanship uh magnus
uh
you certainly made everybody very proud
of
yourself by your sportsmanship in
game two obviously ding had difficulties
in game one but
suddenly he suddenly made a draw then
he's disconnected and he's forfeit
that's not the way you want to win it's
very unfortunate
when did you have it in your mind that
you know let's just
equalize the score
yeah i felt that he he he defended well
in game one and
it was just such a drawn position like
if there was one line
where he could make a draw then then
you know you could sort of say well bad
luck for him but
basically here everything makes every
decent move makes a draw
uh and i i have immense respect for
for being as a chess player and as a as
a human being
and i thought
i i thought against him this was the
only only
correct way and
[Music]
you